au pied des rocheuses se trouvent un
refuge pas comme les autres un
sanctuaire pour des animaux a compris
les chiens loups abandonnés par des
maîtres dépasser ou sauvés de situations
difficiles
les histoires sont toutes différentes
mais ce qui les unit ce sont leurs gènes
ils ont dû loup en eux né de la volonté
de l'homme de croiser les deux espèces
ils n'ont pas seulement gardé
l'apparence de leurs illustres ancêtres
ils portent en eux leur instinct et
l'intelligence qui leur permet de
survivre dans la nature ce qui fait
qu'ils ne seront jamais de simple chien
de compagnie la fondatrice et directrice
du refuge en a elle même fait
l'expérience raconte avoir adopté un
chien loup lorsqu'elle était étudiante
et s'est rendu compte du défi que cela
représente et surtout du nombre de
personnes qui adoptent ces animaux
aveuglément sans savoir dans quoi ils
s'engagent elle a vu ce qu'il advenait
de ces animaux a compris et a décidé de
faire quelque chose pour leur venir en
aide
c'est ainsi qu'est né le sanctuaire yens
oscars 2011
dix ans plus tard 36 chien loup ayant
trouvé refuge ici ils apprennent à
refaire confiance à l'homme
malgré leur passé et les visiteurs
apprennent à les connaître moko à peu de
loups dans ses gènes elle est la plus
sociable de tous malheureusement grandi
dans le mille du loup dangereux et
effrayant alors ce n'est qu'un animal
sauvage qui veut survivre dans la nature
dit elle
ici nous essayons d'éduquer les gens à
propos des chiens loups et des loups et
défaire les nombreux mythes qui les
entourent expliqué que ce sont des
animaux sensibles indépendant gentil et
qu'en fin de compte ils ne veulent qu
être aimé et avoir une belle vie
mais ces nouveaux pensionnaires engendre
de nombreux coups dont la création de
nouveaux enclos pour y faire face jan
hruska lancé une campagne de financement
participatif
chaque construction d'enclos nous coûte
environ 50 mille dollars explique-t-elle
mais il ya aussi les frais de transport
et les soins vétérinaires pour tous ces
animaux au total nous cherchons hamas et
169 dollars
de quoi assurer à ces nouveaux arrivants
une vie tranquille auprès des leurs ici
vincent bonnet radio canada calgary